هيا بنا نذهب إلى الدكتور كاميس اليسي مرحبا بكم في
البرنامج من مدينة غزة أه دكتور اليسي هل
يمكن أن تخبرني أي نوع من التحذيرات
أي نوع من الوقت لديك للهروب
ماذا تفعل في ظل هذا الظرف أه
الحالي
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
أه  دعوتي للانضمام إلى برنامجكم
حسنًا أه التحذير الذي يتلقاه الناس عادةً
أه قبل
هدم منازلهم أو قبل
هدم المبنى هو صاروخ من
الطائرة العسكرية أه لذا فهو
صاروخ صغير الحجم أه يسبب أضرارًا
ربما طابق أو طابقين وخلال
10 دقائق أه ثم الثاني صحيح
يعتمد على الطيار ويعتمد على
الذي يتولى إعطاء الأوامر
هل سيعطي 10 دقائق أو 5
دقائق أو أحيانا أه دقيقة واحدة فقط أه
هذا التحذير  أه أنت فقط تهرب مع
أطفالك وأحيانًا يهرب الناس
دون أن يأخذوا أطفالهم لأنها
كانت قادرة على حمل أحدهم معها ولكن
الآخرين موجودون في الغرفة الأخرى أو في
الطابق الثاني في الطابق الثالث ولا يوجد
وقت وسيقوم المنزل بذلك  تهدم
فوقهم هذا إذا كان أه الطيار هو
الذي يخطط لهدم هذا
المبنى أه بعض الرحمة على هؤلاء
الناس ولكن في مناسبات كثيرة وخاصة
أمس وأول من أمس واليوم
تم إسقاط العديد من المباني على
الأرض دون أي  إنذار مسبق
وبذلك ارتفع عدد
القتلى الفلسطينيين أه من 400 أمس
إلى 870 اليوم بينهم سبعة صحفيين
ثلاثة منهم كانوا يحاولون أه تصوير
مبنى أه يستضيف
وكالات أنباء عالمية أه
وهددوا ذلك المبنى أعطوهم
20 دقيقة  للإخلاء تخيل
إخلاء أه مبنى مكون من 12 طابق في 20
دقيقة هذا أمر لا يصدق وأثناء
محاولتك تصوير هذا أه المبنى أه من
بعيد استهدفت الـF16 هؤلاء
الصحفيين فقتلت ثلاثة منهم اليوم
كنت هناك في مهمة روتينية مهمة
مهمة جدًا ل  لكي
تعتني بالأطفال، هل كنت مستعدًا على
الإطلاق
لهذا جيدًا، كلما ذهبت إلى غزة،
تعلم دائمًا أن هناك خطر حدوث
بعض أعمال العنف أثناء وجودك هناك ولكن
لا،
لم أكن آسفًا على الاستعداد لهذا،
أخبرنا إذا كنت بحاجة إلى ذلك  للذهاب إلى نوع من
الملاجئ أو أي شيء آخر لأنني أستطيع
سماع تلك الانفجارات تنفجر بالقرب منك،
لا توجد ملاجئ
هنا، هل هناك أي منطقة آمنة يمكنك
الذهاب إليها أم نعم أم في الواقع لدي
زوجة أخي هي  فلسطينية تقول
لي ابتعد عن النافذة حتى أكون
بعيدا عن النافذة، ابقى عند زوايا
الجدران الأكثر تحصينا وأم
افتح فمك حتى تكون أم
طبلة الأذن لا تنكسر إذا كان هناك الكثير  من
الضغط لذا أتبع نصيحتها وأنا
في جزء آمن من الغرفة